[موسيقى]
بالطبع 20 عاما غيرت وجهة النظر
لدينا جميعًا هاتف محمول لنأكل الرقصة
لا يمكن التخلص منها فقط
منتج مخدر ولكن أيضًا جلطة شخصية
لا توجد عواطف ، وبالمناسبة ، هكذا بدأ الأمر
منذ دياجليف في بداية القرن العشرين ، هو
مفتوح للعالم
الباليه الجديد الذي لم يكن والأطباء ليسوا كذلك
لم يكن في أي مكان على الإطلاق
صفر حتى فننا هي
فريدة من نوعها
طفل كوبر ثقافته إضعافها
حضاره
كبير وشعور صغير و 9 مؤكد
الثقافة هي الثقافة التي تنفجر
وبالتالي
ينظر الى
تقريبا كل الأيدي تساعد
تحصل الأوركسترا أحيانًا على علامة إيقاع
الآن للعب وكيفية اللعب بالفعل
ليس الأيدي وهذا تعبير عن تعبير العيون
يمكنك إظهار الوجوه بعناية أكبر
chevalier بالنسبة لك يمكن أن يكون الناس archeage
تظهر المزيد من النار
هذا تعبير الوجه كله يدعو جيرجيف
خارج البركة أتوسل إليك أن تفعل
الإصدار الجديد على الفور
من الحافة وفي النهاية سنفعل
هذا الباليه الذي يقارب العشرين
سنوات تذهب مع منزل كامل
تمت دعوته مرتين من قبل رياضي هناك
ابنة معلقة طويلة
ملصقات أصيلة Diaghilevo له نحن هناك
أظهر رقصتي مرتين للفرنسيين
اعجبني كثيرا طلبوا مرتين
أحضر كسارة البندق
والنعناع حبل اللوتس وروسيا
بخصوص هذا سيكون شهر كانون الثاني (يناير) المتحور هنا
إنه مغسلة ولها كيس بعيد
تقنية لك
أكل من بياناتي olga
إنها جلد تشعر بالراحة على أي مبدأ
أنا مثل BC في المقصورة أصبح اليوم
سيكون هو انت
نعل سفرة سفرة نيك و ماسنجرز
وجسم 2xy ويفصل دائمًا
القصص واللواحق
وأنا طريقة دقيقة rivalda ونحن
تعتبر روسية
يشترى
فيلم جديد كلاب 2 ناقص الصلاة في الوجود
التشويق قتل
بيت دالي ريش العالم الأعلى في حيفا
مقابل ثقب الكعك
تشرين الثاني / نوفمبر أوكرانيا كنا نظن العودة إلى الباليه
رقم هاتف نارباش
لكن قوة الإرادة والروح التي تهاجم الوظيفة
يعتبرهم كتاب الخيال العلمي من الشمع والقيقب
على الرغم من أن على القرص intim المال فرح الجوز
هو كايا جدا
سوف تحترق وسائد الخزان والأذن لإيذاء منزل مريح
ارتد المال على مشارف القفص المسار
[موسيقى]
لم تتحدث الإنجليزية على الإطلاق
أنا لا أتحدث الهولندية على الإطلاق
هذا هو شرحنا لها حرفيا
على أصابعها وهي عمليا لا شيء
فهمت مما أقول ، أي هي
يمكن أن يفهم فقط كيف أتحرك
كيف يتحرك الآخرون
كنت صعبًا في العمل الشاق
يحدث بالفعل أيضًا
لحظة عندما تبدأ في الحب
العمل الجاد يحصلون على شيء
ولكن ليس من الصعب نعم فهم هناك شيء ما
يقاتل ويخاف كثيرًا ويحدث كل هذا
هناك ، أيضًا ، في كثير من الأحيان ولكن قليلاً بالفعل
تبدأ في الحب الاجتهاد ما
تسمى باللغة الروسية في هولندا بالطبع
لا توجد مدرسة غربية ، إنها موجودة
هناك بعض الاتجاهات الغربية ولكن
إذا كان يرقص جيدًا فسوف يراك جيدًا
ربما لديه مدرس روسي يرقص
يرى يرى الفروق الدقيقة الخاصة بك ترى أين هو
يمكنك استخدام الأداء
يريد أن يفعل معك ومتى
تبدأ العمل معه بعد ذلك
يطور موهبتك إلى الماء
الكتف أعلاه
نفس أعلى أعلى أعلى خير لا يزال الحريم
هذه هي شد كعب حجمه وظلاله و
زوجة
[موسيقى]
بشكل عام ، المدرسة الرئيسية في سانت بطرسبرغ
ثم ظهرت فكرة إنشاء فرع
مدرسة بطرسبورغ في غاغا
[موسيقى]
أو لا
لدينا هذا الموسم 3 أو الذكرى السنوية الأولى
لقد مرت 25 عامًا في مدارس سانت بطرسبرغ منذ خمس سنوات
سيكون الصندوق الذي يمثل الخلفية الواردة هنا
مظلة هذا الصندوق الذي نظم في
مدرسة الباليه
الباليه الكلاسيكي الروسي هنا
عربات التي تجرها الدواب و
ويبيض لك ، هذا فقط ملكي
راقصة الباليه المفضلة لدي
معظم اللصوص ندير بالفعل سيارات الأجرة تجد الطيور
ثم ocistki المتقاعد الجديد لا أحد
يمكن أن تحل محل واحدة لذلك الآن
آثام فقط باشك كارجات معروف
هلل البارز ل
[موسيقى]
على الرغم من أنني كنت أرقص عندما كنت
صغيرة
شاركت في الأداء وأنا الآن
لا يمكنك أن تقول معاش المتقاعد ، لكن هكذا
قليل
لذا أركض حيث سأقول أن صاحب المعاش
[موسيقى]
ونعيش خلف هذا المنزل تاتيانا
مطاردة فلاديسلاف HTC على والمحيط لك
هدية أساهي الشامل على الرغم من التمويل الكبير
حرب Grigorievich من السحرة والكثير من المتسللين
لا يشعر مارينسكي بالحساسية تجاه السمور
لا يرتديه عن قصد
[موسيقى]
لم تكن لدي القوة التي سيأتي بها هذا
أكثر جدية من لك كان لضبط
نحن نستعد لباليه كسارة البندق منذ عام
كان علي أن أرقص لأول مرة
تصميم رقص الدمى الروسية بواسطة Grigorovich
إنه معقد للغاية هناك معقد
يقفز والآن من قفزة واحدة هو هكذا
القفز مع الاستدارة والهبوط
وقفة كبيرة مع ارتفاع القدم
بعد الهبوط من القفز ، سقطت و
كسرت ركبتي ليس في أربطة مرة واحدة
و
هذه هي اللحظة التي تجعل ذلك
رجل قوي مات بالفعل
المدرسة بجدية شديدة كيف تفعل
من 9 صباحًا إلى 8 مساءً كل يوم ولكن حتى
هو مستعد لذلك الرجل
يواجه حقيقة أنه في ثانية واحدة
يمكن أن تتغير حياتك بشكل جذري
هذا ما جعلني أبدأ التعلم
لن نصل للمعلم
وهذا ما ما زلت أفعله
لسنوات عديدة بشكل عام كان للغاية
لحظة رهيبة لحظة واحدة عندما كان ذلك ضروريا
أدخل الفصل للأطفال الذين لم أفعل بعد
عرفت كيف يجب أن أقول وماذا أفعل
يجب أن أقول وهم جميعًا يقدرونك
إنهم جميعًا ينظرون إليك وينتظرونك جميعًا
إنهم يكسرونك هكذا
تريد أن تفهم من أنت فمن الممكن هناك
لا يمكنك الجلوس على رقبتك
بيرانتيل
لنأخذ أيدينا سر صغير
الدولارات من الإقبال من الأدغال وهذا ساو أنا
الثاني ل 1
يذهبون إلى المدرسة ثم يذهبون كثيرًا في وقت واحد
بعد المدرسة يأكلون شيئًا من الصندوق
في السيارة أثناء ذهابهم وذهبوا على الفور إلى رقص الباليه
[موسيقى]
يعطى ليفيتين ل 48
وأعطى إدوارد الملفات تملأ ذلك
هنا رسومات صوفيا لياخا والرقص ولكن
مازهايف كبسولات شيء أو مافوف ومن
سوفين ولكن أو الانتقال للبقاء
[موسيقى]
لم أخرج إليهم ، أنا نفسي سأكون ساحرًا بإصبعه عليه
قطع تصميم لوحة هومي
حقق أسعار كرة القدم لـ ASUS
مليئة بالبرد
عمل آخر ووعاء وتاتيانا
ملف الحاكم
وشافال وهي النمل هذا ما تريد
غليظ الظهر النوم لتسلق
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
العلاقات الثقافية بين الدول المشتركة
الأهمية
طبعا العلاقات السياسية احيانا
إنه جيد في بعض الأحيان أقل من ذلك بقليل
هذا لا يهم حقًا ما هو مهم
الثقافة رابطة بين الشعوب
[موسيقى]
هيبة و
معنى تقاليدنا عظيم جدا
محرك للكتائب والأبناء السياسيين
غيومهم الرمادية التي تتكاثف
ميدالية على هذه العروض حقيقية
الفنانون الروس هم روس حقيقيون
شركات أوبرا الأوركسترا والباليه
جوقات مدراء الفنانين
سيكون مؤلفو الرقصات دائمًا كذلك
تمكنت من الحصول عليها لأنها قوية للغاية
التقاليد ذات أهمية كبيرة
عموما اليوم في الغرب ل
السحر الروسي الطليعي vich Valia الذي
يحتوي
في الجحيم كان لدي صورة كاريكاتورية هنا و
عموما تشمس مربع مثل القبر
لوحة تاس عندما ديفيد الحديثة
دهان
على الرغم من أنني أعشق ماليفيتش كما تفهم
الطليعة الروسية هي أعظم شيء
وكذلك الأيقونة الروسية
[موسيقى]
السكك الحديدية الروسية و
مضروبة في عمل الخزف ، لدينا
صعوبات
نحن نملح نهر لينا 1 بشدة بالهواء و
دعا بوم وجاف وأميال متفاجئة
خلية نهر تندا kabira wa la
جزيرة مايرون لك
تعهد daiquiri mylife tatyana
والاختناق si si بالكاد يتنفس
يوتيوب عن الكنوز والجلد
لكن لم تكن هناك مواقع أيضًا على بالة البركان
للإنترنت لا يوجد شيء نتعامل معه هنا
إنه يعمل لقد ولدت في بطرسبرغ
جدي ، لم يكن مصدر إلهام لهذا الحب
حب الفن للهندسة المعمارية
في كل مكان منذ 4 سنوات لدي واحدة في كل مكان
المدينة واخذني الى المتاحف وكان جدا
غالبًا ما ذهبوا إلى متحف الإرميتاج والمتحف الروسي
لا أتذكر ما لا يقوله ولكن أيضًا
إنه لمن دواعي سروري أن أمشي
جد
وجاري تاتيانا ، الكمين الخاص بي ، حتى في صميم الموضوع
طوابع روسيا
المؤلفون على باب منزلي ليسوا مألوفين
واه سلام ahimas زوج قرنية ليكون
رواه طاحونة الجيش رمي
[موسيقى]
معرض تم إنشاؤه في عام 2015 لا أريد
لأقول إن لدي فكرة ذات مرة
تصبح مالك معرض إنشاء معرض موضوع
المزيد في الدنمارك أعلم أنه صعب ولكن
لقد حدث ذلك وحدث ما حدث
الظروف التي حصلت على هذا المبنى
وهنا نسخ من مكان عظيم للجبل و
حتى الحرب على كرسي ، حسنًا ، ماذا تتخيل
تخيلت أن هذا هو شكل المبنى
عندما اشتريناه
استثمرنا الكثير من المال
تسربت
إعادة بناء هذه الطبعة ، وهذا هو ، نحن
صنع معرض احترافي من هذا القبيل
تقريبا لم أره هنا.
[موسيقى]
كنا هدايا مكان الوقت مثير
أنا شبكة sungyu يمكنك استخدامها لفتح
يمكنك مسلسل Dyakova في المقهى
قيمة للحصول عليه يمكن أن يكون smoby أنا بالفعل
تعمل صورة psb لخلية queers
وضع معرض elex
يجب أن يكون صعبًا
تمت ترقيته على مستوى ما بحيث الناس
جاء كل الفنانين إلي
المحترفين وهذا ما يميز هذا
صالة عرض
ها هو الدنماركي لذا يقدمون لي
على سبيل المثال عرض المزيد من الدنماركية
الفنانين لجذبهم
لكني لا أحبهم كثيرًا.
عندما نناقش أنا وزوجي ما نريد
معرضنا ، نريده أن يكون
متناغم تصب اسمه يعتقد
المكان الذي بدأ هو القرف الذاتي على
الوقوف معنا كتلة كل bonita منهم
نفسك مع التيفوس والتمويل
اختيار الملابس الداخلية عند وصولك كبيرة
المعارض لأنك تشعر بالسوء هناك
يتم تدمير مجال الطاقة الخاص بك و
لذلك من الصعب جدًا شرح شيء ما
علينا أن نتخيل كيف نرسم
امزج كيف يجمعون جيدًا شيئًا ما
ليس من الضروري أن تعرف
لا يعتقدون أن هذا ليس ضروريًا
كما يقولون فتح الجنون اسأل
على ملاحظة آسف لخمسين إلى أوشم.
نعم سونورا
[موسيقى]
الآن كذب العمل أكثر من اللازم
عشرين عاما ولكن الريح إعادة هيكلة الدلق
كان لدينا شخص ما خارج حدود nga لشركتنا
ومن الصعب تغيير البلد كله
ويمكن حتى للحياة الكاملة لشخص واحد
ربما جيدة جدا
عظيم ربما لديك الحب هناك ولكن
إنه عالم مختلف تمامًا ، إنه عالم مختلف تمامًا
تبدو
[موسيقى]
ailanthus حول وجه الحي إلى الكوبيه الجديدة
يركب أكثر
والحبل مشدود وبالطبع في الأسلحة
أسود رمادي القاتل
وبعد ثلاثة أيام قرروا العيش معًا و
لقد كنا معًا لأكثر من عشر سنوات ونحن سعداء بذلك
كل 10 أقسام فقط
سيفان تولي سمور لأنه يجب أن يكون هو نفسه أصدقاء
ليغو هنري
جولة sammich حتى حافة وجهه
و Yesenka من ماثيو الريح و البقية
الأطفال قماش أساء لا بحر البلطيق
سأقول مرحبا بكم في جميع معرضنا
نحن نحب أن نجمع الضيوف هنا و
يسعدنا رؤيتكم جميعا اليوم
معرض صغير في افتتاحنا
القيمين على معرض الضرب لا شيء
لدينا الوقت ليتم استدعاؤنا
لأنه وصل للتو لذلك لا
كان لديه الوقت لفعل أي شيء يجب أن يفعل كل شيء
افعلها أثناء التنقل
البطاقات المعتادة تستعد للمعرض
[موسيقى]
نحن الآن مرضى لم نعد نكتب لك
تقديم مجموعته
لدينا هذا المعرض لا يستحم جيدا
ما زلنا نعتقد أنه مثير للاهتمام وحتى الآن
ما زلت تريد الحفاظ على القوى في أسلوب الحياة
قمت بتسميم القطب وأخرى تصف حوالي 1 سياج
من اللعبة والثنائي 2 لوسي ليو
1 تصنيف الإضافات هم بحر من المفتاح
سقط
أنا لم أرَ دنماركيًا واحدًا حتى الآن
أتيت إلى هنا وقالت أي شيء
في كل مكان يا كم هو مثير للاهتمام يا كم هو جميل
[يضحك]
ريكام
[موسيقى]
tatiana ura lehrbuch الهواء في المرحاض
أعطت الفيلات هي مشاركتك لي أو
مقالتي هي al motanut نعم ليست طوابع
وجوه ومرق كهف روسي
يعتبر أنه قد عمل بشكل جيد
رعايته بينما يقتل الرجل مؤخرته
يقفز خارج شططي
تانيا اليامين هنا كل تقنياتهم
أعلن الجيلاتين الأثيني بغباء ثم المراجعة
من الضروري
بسرعة مع وليمة عرض الجدول ساكين واحد
الطريقة أو العيش هي أسئلة خداع تاتيانا
ومن السهل الحصول على طعامين بعميل
[موسيقى]
عندما رأيتني خلفية التزلج
لذلك العقلي بعد أن انفتح بغزارة
راقصة الباليه لأنها كانت بعمر 60 سنة
ناتاشا تلاحظ الآن بعض
التزحلق
راقصة الباليه تانيوشكا ألبينا أحبك و
يقول هذا عدة مرات في اليوم
أبحث عن مكان أمان ألفا كليك يونغ فينرودا
للدكتورة تاتيانا أنت الأول أو مجنون ش
احتضنك هنا
اسمي هو المفضل لدي أو جنية المعرفة
كليتشكو هو أن الباب هو ذلك الجنية
الآن يعرف أن الجنية ولكن لديه
انا افرا
مقالات chack ولكن أيضًا بالاختزال الدنماركي i
اريد اسطورة
أفلام
على رائع ومع ذلك كل يوم نحن
نتحدث معه عدة مرات على حدة
شخصيًا ، نحن في المسبح في الصباح يارب
شكرا لك باللغة الروسية وهو أيضا
شكرا لك يا رب ، الأمر يتعلق بما نحن عليه
اجتمع على ذلك من أجل
يا على ظهور الخيل
نعم ، والسرعة
هذا اروع حبيبتي
مضحك.
الغرض الرئيسي من اليوم هو إظهار
يعرف الفن من بعيد و
فنانينا ببطء
إنه صعب أو لا شيء أنا معجب به
بذور اللفت موهوبة ، وأنا أعلم أن الكثير منها لديها
ورقة مصطلح للتحدث عن لا تظهر لهم
ولكن هنا كسفراء
هذه الدولة
يوري بورلان للتوسع هنا نبحث عن فارك
ليس
هذا الخزان خارج خط العمل بالنسبة لي
مختلف
فنان بدون اي ثمن انتظام
تأثير عند بوابة تسعير بابيكوف و
من أجل التدريبات في المراقبة ، تعثرت
الحصول على نوعية جيدة
مع الأعراف
[موسيقى]
بالطبع نريد تعزيز
فن لأننا نملك
مدرسة غير عادية و
واحد من الباقين على قيد الحياة فقط
هذا العالم
[موسيقى]
منة سر واحد من جميع الروسية ولكن
إذا كان هناك شيء
الروسي الروسي يرتفع عاليا عليه
الارتفاع الذي يمكنهم تسلقه
تسلق منظر الوحدة في العالم
[موسيقى]
لدينا موقف صعب جدا للفنان
أنت تفهم ، ولكن اليوم لا يوجد مفهوم
الاحتراف أو الخير
التلوين برسم جيد للثواني
الفنانين اليوم قد لا تكون قادرة على
ألفت
اليوم هو علامة جيدة
بدأت في شراء وبعد ذلك تماما
بجدارة
وبعض الأسعار التي تستحقها جيدة
صور الاشتراكيين الذين تنزل معهم
الواقعية كانت رائعة جدا
سادة
إنها وظيفة قوية جدًا بالنسبة لي
يترك انطباع
دعا عمل الناس براتب
دفعوا القمح ، لذلك حصدوا و
هنا يشتركون جميعًا في كل الأشياء الذكية المبهجة
ما أصوات أيام العمل التي يمكنني الحصول عليها
سأعود ولن يكون هناك جوع أندريه فيلاتوف
ووجه Lyokha صب مرة واحدة حول تلك الصور
طارت خيمة روس لمن لك
الشباب الصنوبر
طبخ أو نشأت
كل تلك المجموعات التي تم تصديرها إلى
90 سنة
[موسيقى]
الحصول عليها للجمع والتحصيل
تظهر للعالم كله أتذكر
المعرض الأول في الشرق الأوسط للأنواع
جلبنا
تم التخطيط للفن السوفيتي
الشهر ونتيجة لذلك أربعة أشهر كاملة
القاعات والناس بإعجاب كبير
طار من جميع أنحاء العالم إلى
انضم إلينا السوفياتي
فن بكى الناس في وجهي
لم تصدم الصور
[موسيقى]
ثم انتقل في الحياة للترويج
فننا من خلال الشطرنج من خلال منجم
[موسيقى]
إذا
باريير من تصوير النهاية يتحدث عن سيم
أنت بحاجة إلى شخص يتمتع بالجمال حتى الآن
أحب المكان هناك 3 ملاعق كبيرة
الفنيين أو إظهار الأصدقاء ل
لديك مع الفساد
[موسيقى]
أنا لا أموت جميعًا من لي أو لك
انها ببطء انها تحتاج الى المنتج ذاته
ونتائج المخاض ليطير
بصدق يحب صراخه بصدق
أحب الفن وقرر حقا
اصنع أفضل بياضات الثوم في العالم
وأنا أحبه حقًا
سلسلة كل ما يفعله بصدق و
بكل صراحه
[موسيقى]
أنواع المعرض 10-ki تغادر في naboo
الاسبوع الثالث
حالة طوارئ
أعد حزم أندري فيلاتوف وأنت ترى هذا
شبكة وكأنني سوف تذوب مكالمته هنا
سيستري ليفانتي لا تقل عن سنتين صلصة
دائرة كهربائية
نظرت إلى شكل الزجاجة وقررت
استعمال
الفكرة الرئيسية هي أنه كان على الطاولة و
الرجل الذي يتذوق نظرة الخمر
التسمية ويبدأ الفنان بدراسة
جوجل لذلك هناك مصلحة لدينا
لا يتم الاستمتاع بالفن فقط
النبيذ جيدًا وهنا سبب وجيه للتعرف عليه
على الفنان التحدث لمناقشة البؤرة الاستيطانية
[موسيقى]
التقطت dopov serdica سيعتمد
قوة عضلات الركبة
من الإصدارات إلى الصفر إلى أعلى الكل
اشترى هلام ولكن بانت الرصاص
أتمنى لو كان لدينا أساس من القوة كان لدينا هذا
الصيف إنجاز عظيم مشهور جدا
لاعب كرة القدم مثل ديفيد بيكهام أمرنا
الخمر في مطعم النحت و النزول على السجدة
وقد أحبها حقًا
ثم توقف في المنزل فولتا يوم
جون أو حاول معًا ولكن
في الصباح ، أطلقوا النار على زجاجة فارغة
صورة repin الخاص بك instagram وكتب
اليد شكرا لينا العظيمة و 58
تعرف على الصورة مليون شخص
repin 17 أكتوبر
وقعت العقود مع الولايات المتحدة
امريكا من ابو ظبي
وسط ألمانيا والمملكة المتحدة
سيرة خاملة
[موسيقى]
مشى
فيديو جنسي على الرغم من أنك بعض في الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
حمار البولي أميد
بافل مسمار 7
[ __ ]
اليكس
يوري غاغارين في السالكي لإقناع الناس بعد كل شيء
إذا استلقيت وتركت تحلق هو
لن تتعلم
من المهم التأكيد على ما هو أكثر
أعظم واحد هو الأعظم بيننا ، هذا هو Gagarin و
هذه الصورة لها هي الأولى من نوعها
ماغنوم والسنة الرابعة عشرة بدأ المشروع معها
وذهبت هذه الزجاجة أولاً مع هذه الزجاجة
عمل أظهر ما أحبه
طفولتي ما زلنا نمتلك موسيقى رائعة
لذلك ، كل من Gagarin و
رحمانينوف والعمارة وفرنسا
لذلك كل هذا معا هذا وهذا
أعطى التأثير
[موسيقى]
من خلال توافر مكررات zetec
الوعل
الوجبات الجاهزة ولكن لك في اي تيونز وأين
اسأل acme لم يعط
[موسيقى]
على ابن السجن من آراء اسم العائلة 9 حلقات
في أنف نفسه سمكة لصديق منفذ
[موسيقى]
زيارة السفن لذلك اعتقد ديفي
إلغاء تعطينا لن نتركه
الثلاثاء و
برز الجوع الإيجابي البوم لدينا
[موسيقى]
هناك شيء خاص في الموسيقى الروسية
فريد من نوعه يلامس
قلب الإنسان مثل سان سير
قال التوت للتو أن لدي موسيقى
بالنظر إلى نفسي بالطبع
ولد في القلب يذهب إلى القلب
أعتقد أن الموسيقى هي الحب
المستمعين الكامنين وفي المحطة
تعال إلى الحفلات الموسيقية الروسية
فناني الأداء الروس وهم
أشعر أنه من المستحيل ألا أشعر
ليس من الضروري التحدث أو التصرف مع
ملصقات الموسيقى على الاطلاق هذه ليست كذلك
يطالب نفسه سيقول كل شيء
ويخترق روح البشرية
[موسيقى]
بالضرورة مدينة ليدار ثلاثية الأبعاد بالمناطق المأهولة بالسكان
دوران
اكتب صندوق رئيس كوكو رئيسه
تحتوي
برعم الشركة في صورة أنت فيها جار
للبوابة
قيادة جيدة للطريق كل شتاء عالمي بالخارج
القانون على نتيجة شكل و
العقل وراء هذه الحلقات عالم الشتاء porsche ag
الكلبة ريكسي إنه بيت قطة
سترة لبعثات تسمية الغذاء لك
قاد لوضع الأزرق أثناء المشاركة
استقل الصندوق 30 ألف زجاجة في السنة
إجمالي الإنتاج
70 في المائة من المبيعات في فرنسا
فرنسا تحب روسيا تحب روسيا
الفن والعديد من الفرنسيين لا يفعلون ذلك حقًا
يعرفون أن شاغال ، على سبيل المثال ، ولد في
نمت الإمبراطورية الروسية من قبل فيتبسك
ما هذا الفنان الفرنسي
الفنانين والنحاتين الحاليين لدينا
لها نجاح كبير في طار الغرب
يجرؤ على فننا ولكن هناك
القيود المفروضة على متحفنا
يمكن عرضها ، على سبيل المثال ، في نفس
الولايات المتحدة ، وهذا هو ، هناك مباشرة
منافسة
الانطباعي الفرنسي يقف الفاتورة
150 مليون والمطاردات السوفيتية
مليون دعونا فجوة 150 بالطبع
2 3 ستكون طويلة
أي ، شخص ما سيتم إنزاله من أجل
ارتفاع الصورة وبعد كل شيء في الفجوة 150 مرة
لا يمكن أن تكون كلها ذاتية للغاية
كل بلد له تفضيلاته
نزرع قطع أصبع التلال عليه
أغلى خنزير في العالم وحده حتى الآن
تم بيع النصف مقابل 5 ملايين
جنيه كل نصف أي كله
طريق ريفي ملتصق هو 10 مليون
جنيه أكثر بكثير من 10
مليون دولار
لدينا عائلة كبيرة جدا ، ولدينا أندريه
طفلين من زواجه الأول.
لا تشرب ، لا تقلق ، لا تقلق
ولدينا 4 قواسم مشتركة أخرى ، الأكبر منها
5 سنوات وليس لدى أي منهم توأمان بمفرده
كلنا طقس حتى كاتيا الفتاة الكبرى
و Uliana M14 8 والأصغر سنا بشكل عام
يوليو
خامس له فقط أو ثلاثة فاسيا واثنان
الوادي ليس كذلك
و 8 أشهر لدينا أب كبير
كان أندري يريد دائمًا عائلة كبيرة وأنا
أتمنى لو كان لدي واحد آخر ولكن لم أستطع.
تخيل أنه سيكون هناك الكثير
أنا سعيد للغاية لأن هناك الكثير
عديدة
[موسيقى]
المفتاح الذي تفهمه
أسفل مثل هذه المكافأة العالية
مجد الأم ، أنا أحلم بذلك حقًا
هنا زوجتي حصلت على هذه الأم
كلمة 7 زائد تصلي التنمية
يتكلم الروسية الفرنسية
الإنجليزية والصينية
ربما الأصعب بالنسبة لهم ، لكننا
قررت أن هذه ستكون إضافة رائعة في
المستقبل لن يظهر معنا ومع الكبار
علق أهم شيء في المنزل
ضحك الاطفال
أصبح أبًا رائعًا بالطبع فهو على دراية
كل ما يهم في حياة الأطفال
ظهور معجبين جدد في الحياة
كاتي النجاح الإبداعي أوليانا
يعرف أن كل شيء لديه أصدقاء جورا
انه في المدرسة
أعتقد أنه يحب أطفاله بشدة
أهم شيء في حياته
[موسيقى]
هنا اثنان من الشركات المصنعة في فرنسا
استخدام شعار النبالة لبلدنا الكريستال
الشمبانيا هناك شعار النبالة للإمبراطورية الروسية
لأن نيكولاس الثاني
كان له تأثير كبير على تصميم الزجاجة
وهنا شعار النبالة للاتحاد السوفيتي
المستخدمة في قائمتنا
لقد ولدت في الاتحاد السوفيتي
لقد نشأت بيناجادي
هذا الفن وبالتالي استخدام
اليوم أقدم إمكانياتي
الفن السوفيتي من خلال المعارض
النبيذ من خلال الشطرنج
[موسيقى]
في عام 2012 عقدنا في معرض تريتياكوف
بطولة العالم للشطرنج 5 مليون
زار الناس
البث عبر الإنترنت
كانت التغطية أكثر من 90 دولة في العالم
وكان رمز المباراة هو فيكتور بوبكوف
فريق العمل يستريح
[موسيقى]
في 0.12 بطلة العالم كانت بقيادة فيلاتوف
رئيس الاتحاد 12 4
هذه الصلصة هي فرصتي
علمني أبي أن ألعب الشطرنج
تصرفت العاطفة تقريبا كل من
الحياة مرتبطة
لا تخبر الفتيات يلعبن كثيرا
حسنًا ، لكنهم بالفعل قطط بالغة و
uliana yura على القاعة ليس فقط في الآونة الأخيرة
منذ سنوات ، ها هو لعبة الشطرنج تمامًا
طفل ولكن في أبطال بوجاتشيفا بعد ذلك
الشارع الذي تتجذر من أجل يوري ليزا
كاتيوشا تطلب مني ألا أتحدث عنك
كل شيء ممتع للغاية أحب دراسته
الحب اكتشف أحب الفن كلنا
مثل ذلك وكأن أبي يسلم
الفرح والسرور ان لعبة الشطرنج
فلماذا لا أريد إرضاء الكهنة
يتساءل عدد قليل من الشطرنج كم
الفن غطاء المنتخب لا يزال الفن
أنا مهتم أكثر بصور هذه المجال
الذي يعجبني أكثر
جمع الأب هو المطبوعات و
مائة sadko لأن هذه الصورة
أخبرت الأمير يتعلم من
كان بوت معرضًا في لندن أتينا إليه
لنسج الصورة واندفعوا لا إطلاقا
فهم من كان صادكوف ، أي نوع
الشخصية
لا أحد يستطيع بسبب الحاضرين في ذلك الوقت
ليس هناك ابي ايلينا اقول من
مثل هذا sadkova بكلمات واضحة لأن
لم تصله فقط ، لكني فقط
مؤخرا درس هذا العمل قبل أسبوع
درست المؤامرة أنا فقط بحرية
أخبر ما كان يبحث عن أسطورة
هذا كل شئ
[موسيقى]
على عدم العمل أبي دعا الوزن
تصل إلى 1 سنة
كتب العمل على نطاق واسع خمسين
السنة الثامنة
عامل مستودع
مغازلة
هذه العجلات تتبعها فتاة
الذي يحاول المغازلة تحب
يمكن أن نرى من العمل أنك لا تغازل ، ولكن
تتظاهر بأنها لا تلاحظ
وهنا ، كرمز ، هذه أوراق هذا
الربيع بين
ويبدأ الحب وكذا
يبدو أن كل شيء قاسي للغاية في نفس مستودع الطريق
عزيز
بالضبط ما هو الأكثر أهمية هو بالفعل في الداخل
عندما يكون هناك غش محتمل في الاعتبار
فن
ولدي جزء لا يصدق منه
التفاهم والحب لأندريه فاسيليفيتش
يشعر عندما تحمل الصورة الطاقة
يناسب الصورة وهو على الفور
يعرّف وتحفة
أم لا وهذه طبعا موهبة ويحبها
فن
أنا أحبه وربما هنا لدينا
تتطابق المصالح
[موسيقى]
لا يوجد بلد الآن لن يكون
مشاكل وشعور جيد جدا
كثير من الناس سئموا من هذا
تعبت من السياسة تعبت من الحروب
هذه كيف تؤثر للأسف على حياتنا
ولكن بعد أن يعتمد المستمع
مغادرة القاعة الموسيقية
ينسى الكثير من الأشياء
موجود في كل بلد
ملاك
أنهم
كان
أ 7 أ أعطى الأولاد كيندا اسمًا
وتحف نية وحتى
سيلفس
لي أنت كولمان الحب السريع والغاضب
أعتقد أن كل أم تريد
كانت الفتاة تعمل في الطيران واللغة هي
الكثير من هذا العمل
والآن لديها بالفعل
الهامش الفني خطير جدا
مما يسمح لها بالفعل الآن على ما أعتقد
حتى أنه
وقريباً قد يبدأ البعض
تكون الحفلة الرئيسية
يعلم
تضخيمه بفم مسنن لإخباره
لديك أفضل ما في كثيفة على الأثرياء على الإطلاق
هذه الجيوش وما فوق الكواليس
المشي لمسافات طويلة والكونغ فو
وظيفية خاصة انتظار اللجان
يعتقد بتروفسكي أنه ينحدر من
لم يكن لديك المحكمة سوف تعطي الصلصة. شبابيك
لكن
نعم لتحقيق هذا المستوى
اعمل بجد
[موسيقى]
نفصلها لك 8
قم بتسجيله في معيار الشريط الجانبي
dobkina كوطن عداء فولتا
صوت المجال
[موسيقى]
وجاءت جدا بارتون مساج الجولف و
ماري دون إمباث تفكيك نفسها
الجسم لمزيد من البشر
مجموعة لحم بغي دونك
انها ترقص بشكل جيد جدا وجيد جدا
توكسون تبدو صغيرة جدا
انه حقا كسارة البندق قليلا مثل
ها هي لعبة يمكنني أن أحصل عليها من المال وغرز في الحمام
6 في إسبانيا وباس
نصف صف التعبئة وهذا هو و
دائما و sokol.ua تغفو و لفترة وجيزة دافع
على جائزة لأسفل
سؤال سؤال مجنون لا تامبوف
ابن البليت dmitruk كنت تغلب على القاع
وضع خاص على رالي يوتيوب
[موسيقى]
ساعدت ذلك السعر العالمي لسعر الفائدة على علي
فيلم wimp
بخير على الرغم من متر باتيل وأنا أعيش
القسائم حتى لا يفعل الأطفال الهولنديين
الرقص
لا يوجد مثل هؤلاء الأطفال الذين ترقصون هكذا
givin zapfino فازت بالمركز الأول فيها
فئتهم العمرية في المنافسة على
هنا هولندا في غاغا
المركز الأول
[موسيقى]
أضف العصير و
من نظام الطاقة وو سونغ liqpay elsie
فنتون كل 3 ndfl
ظهرت infox.ru الاسم من اللص ومن
ليس شخصا أنت ووضعي
من الذئب في أذني التجار والوزن
ولم تضف مسيرتي بعد
تاريخ لجنة أعلى وضع قرونهم على حد سواء
وقالت السلع لارينا ذلك أو مجنون آخر
بالأمس هناك 2 افتراء نصف فتحة بالسيوف
وهو وهو يسجد وآخر بالأسعار
الوظيفة أنا في المنزل الشرطي رائع و
تاتيانا وجوردسون هي الأقوى و
الخاص بك ولكنك نمت الدعوى
[موسيقى]
قد يوم و
منصة وعاء
مساعدة الاصبع الأولاد
هيا غرام اليبيكوفيتش والموت س
سيتم تمديد التأشيرة
ليس
نحن سوف
المدرسة الروسية مطلوبة في كل مكان في
في جميع مسارح العالم الروس و
رقصات أفضل
الهولندي
رقم
في الباليه الكلاسيكي ، على سبيل المثال ، في
مقدمو مسرح أمستردام الملكي
عازفون منفردون
آنا تسيغانكوفا زميلتي السابقة
مسرح كبير
a0 الأحمر السابق في كراسنويارسك الرائدة
عازف منفرد ثم عازف منفرد سابق
مسرح ستانيسلاف في موسكو
المدرسة الروسية هنا مطلوبة
بالطبع هنا قيادة الرقص الهولندي
عازف منفرد
[موسيقى]
هذا يقول مهمة خاصة نحملها
أرواحنا تحمل الثقافة عندما نفعل ذلك
نأتي إلى بلدان حيث تسير الأمور على هذا النحو
المواجهة هي مجنونة كما تعلم و
لكنك تعتقد أنك بحاجة إلى رمي الطماطم وداخلها
النهاية فهم مقدار الصراخ
الروس الشجعان كلهم ​​وها أنت ذا
هناك يخرج مرة أخرى ويبدأ يمكنه ذلك
الروسية boo-boo-boo لكنها تنهض وتنسى
كل شيء في العالم تولى الروسية براما الروسية
أعتقد أن السيد شرير
نعم ، ينسج مؤامرة ضد قل قليلا
شعور
يجب أن تكون حذرا هنا
ها أنت تستمع
وجميع الأعمال بالنسبة لنا هي قمامة تمامًا و
الكثير بالطبع نفعله الآن
بطريقتي أنا سعيد جدا
أن المواسم الروسية استؤنفت بطريقة ما
خاصة وأن جزءًا من عائلتي يعيش في
باريس وتدرك جيدا
متوفرة
ما هو الانطباع التاريخي
مواسم دياجليف الروسية التي كانت
قبل
الأسماك ولا تزال مخزنة هناك دي عارية
أتذكر العروض في مسرح شاتليه
باريس مذهلة معلقة تماما
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]